and i don't think the
um
the trend is toward exclusivity but
there could be
you know early release available for
xbox before other platforms we'll have
to see about that but they're very
valuable franchises and they should be
uh
immediately of value to microsoft okay
so the lawyers will be getting on that
right away that's um the first item on
the to-do list i think about activision
and how it was really struggling with
some workplace culture issues misconduct
over its treatment of women the ceo
bobby kotec was under a lot of pressure
what does he bring to the table he's
going to stay through the transition but
after that it's goodbye bobby
i'm not aware of
of
what's going to happen with uh
with the that per specific personnel
issues or
or bobby codex uh involvement
but uh certainly it it is probably good
timing when the company is experiencing
these these negative uh
uh press issues and and culture issues
uh
the
microsoft's oversight will help bring
some stability to that situation and
hopefully improve the environment yeah
we we understand that the um phil
spencer who is head of microsoft gaming
will be in charge of activision blizzard
and consolidating that
i want to ask about regulatory approval
because activision blizzard obviously
operates in a lot of different markets
which means there's going to be a lot of
different
regulatory bodies that need to okay this
deal is there any reason for you to
think that this is going to be
complicated
i don't i don't think so the video game
industry is uh very very diverse there's
in my index in the
index that drives the gamer etf there's
a 112
companies
so there's plenty of opportunity for
competition there's plenty of
other products out there and
you know trends change and and the
popularity of certain franchises change
so microsoft has an incredible
opportunity with this acquisition but
they also have a challenge to keep these
franchises relevant and of good quality
right i'm just looking at the gamer etf
and the holdings there and activision
blizzard is the third biggest company
holding
what happens
once it's absorbed into microsoft does
microsoft take over and and becomes the
third biggest holding of that etf
uh no the the index rebalances four
times a year
and it has four different categories
that that the stocks are placed in
uh i i won't get into too many details
of the methodology but the methodology
is available online
uh etfmg can provide that and i believe
my website as well
but the uh the stocks are equally
weighted within each of these four tiers
which is an approach that
treats
all of these companies very very
similarly
and nothing gets really overweighted
unless it uh breaks out in between
rebalances so at the next rebalance
everyone goes back to equal standing got
it got it okay well we mentioned uh take
two buying zynga and now microsoft
buying activision blizzard you don't see
necessarily any problems with that being
approved by regulatory bodies what's
next who else is up for grabs ted
there there's lots of opportunities for
acquisition in the in the gaming markets
uh
by public companies buying private
companies uh and public companies uh
buying or merging with other public
companies
i don't have any insight into the next
acquisition at this time
but uh certainly i think that this uh
acquisition and the take-two acquisition
uh opens eyes about the value of of this
industry and uh
and it might uh protect or increase
valuations across the board yeah and
we're seeing that with all these
different shares of video game
publishers getting a big boost in the
wake of this announcement
um with this acquisition microsoft has
said it becomes the world's number two
or i should say number three video game
company after 10 cent and sony which is
really interesting because it would be
the the biggest us company which makes
me wonder obviously microsoft is not the
only big tech company with a lot of cash
on its balance sheet
where's apple where's amazon where's
facebook in this do you anticipate that
they will become buyers of video game
companies as well
i think uh
apple is is focusing uh on the uh i
think they're big opportunities with
a mixed reality
headset and as far as the content
apple
may start
acquiring
companies that are making games but i
don't see the timing of that happening
immediately once they have a platform in
place with this
with a headset which at first doesn't
seem like it's a consumer price headset
they could become more interested
uh amazon has their own game studio they
definitely could
uh be in the market for
uh additional intellectual property
and uh the third company you mentioned
oh 10 cent they're they always are
trying to get into
um
any uh situation that
that uh they don't have access to right
now what about facebook ted
uh
meta meta excuse me meta
yeah they just actually uh
uh
i saw something going on about their
ticker symbol or or uh uh today but
um the
meta is uh
is such a a socially driven company that
owning game development i
it's possible but i i would think that
those other companies might be
in in front of them when it comes to
making acquisitions for for game
software companies got it ted [ __ ]
thank you so much for joining us and
sharing uh your perspective on what this
microsoft acquisition of uh activision
blizzard means for the video game
industry at large this is bloomberg
quick take i'm scarlet foo